We have the same two unitary gates as in the previous example, and these symbols right here represent standard basis measurements
Specifically after the two
unitary operations are performed, a standard basis measurement
is performed on Y
and the result is overwritten
to the classical bit, B, and similarly X is measured and the result is written to the bit A.
Here you can see that the Qubits X and Y continue on after they're measured.
It's pretty common
though that we don't care all that much about Qubits
after they're measured.
Sometimes all we care about
is the measurement result. And in a case like that, we can use the shorthand
style that you see here
where measurements have Qubits coming in and classical bits coming out.
The understanding here is that
once the Qubits are measured, they're just discarded or ignored and the classical measurement
outcome is carried forward.
Now as the series continues, we'll be seeing many
examples of quantum circuits and they'll typically
be much more complicated than the very simple
examples that we just saw.
As I mentioned earlier, different symbols are
used for different gates.
Single cubic gates are usually
just written as squares with a letter indicating
which operation it is.
Sometimes these different
gates are color coded to mean different things, but
we'll ignore that for now.
We've already seen the
Controlled NOT gate.
Swap gates are denoted
as you see right here, And Toffoli gates and Fredkin gates
are denoted as you see right here.
Remember that a Toffoli gate is a controlled Controlled NOT gate and a Fredkin gate is
a controlled swap gate.
So these symbols are
consistent with the idea that a control Qubit is
indicated by a solid circle with a line connecting it
to the gate it controls.
In general, controlled Qubits
don't need to be on the top and these gates don't have
to act on neighboring Qubits, meaning that these gates
can be stretched across
other Qubits that they don't act on, and we'll see that
happening in future lessons.
One more thing that we often do when using the quantum circuit model is to view arbitrary unitary operations
on any number of Qubits
as if they're single gates like you see right here.
Just by drawing a rectangle with a label corresponding
to whatever unitary operation it is.
In this case it's some
unitary operation U.
Of course, we don't know
what U is from this diagram, we have to assume that
U is defined somehow or that we're considering some arbitrary
unitary operation U, perhaps. It could be for example that
we just wanna think about U as if it's a subroutine in
the interest of clarity.
We also use this notation
that you see right here for a controlled U operation
where the control Qubit is indicated by a solid circle
just like we had before.
So that's a brief introduction
to the quantum circuit model. And as I said before, we will see many more
examples of quantum circuits
as we continue on in the series.
In the next part of the lesson, we're going to take a
look at inner products, orthonormality and projections, which are very important notions
in quantum information and computation.
We'll start with inner products.
Remember that when we
use the direct notation, a Ket is a column vector
and a Bra is a row vector,
and specifically the
Bra vector corresponding to a given column vector is the conjugate transpose
of that column vector.
So for this vector right here, we obtain the corresponding Bra vector by transposing the vector
as if it's a matrix,
which amounts to laying it on its side and then taking the complex conjugate of each of the entries.
Now, suppose that we have two Kets with the same number of entries like this.
If we form this bracket right here, which simply means that
we take the product of the Bra and the Ket,
as if they're matrices,
then we obtain this expression
that you see right here, which is a scaler, or in
other words a complex number.
This value is called the inner
product of these two vectors.
You can also think about inner products in terms of vectors of the
form that you see right here where the vectors are expressed
as linear combinations
of standard basis vectors.
The inner product of these vectors is defined in the same way as
before, Bra Psi times Ket Phi which we can express
as a product like this.
And if we compute and simplify, we're left with this expression right here for the inner product, which is analogous to what we had before,
except this time we're
taking the sum over elements in our classical state set, which is sigma in this particular case.
Here's an example that's meant to give you a geometric picture for
how inner products work.
Here I've drawn a circle
in a two-dimensional space corresponding to a Qubit, and as long as we restrict our attention
to vectors having real number entries, we can draw them as points on this plane.